y
[Música]
al menos 66 muertos en la ciudad
brasileña de petrópolis en el estado de
río de janeiro las inundaciones y
deslizamientos causados por las lluvias
extremas mientras continúa a
contrarreloj la búsqueda de
sobrevivientes bajo los escombros
ampliamos desde el río de janeiro
la otan y eeuu dicen que no hay pruebas
de la retirada de las tropas rusas de la
frontera con ucrania anunciada por el
presidente vladimir putin ayer mientras
que moscú reiteró que más soldados están
saliendo de crimea hoy
tienen lugar en parís la cumbre de los
líderes de países occidentales
implicados en la lucha antiterrorista en
la región del sahel se espera que
francia anuncie el retiro de sus tropas
de malí tras una misión de 10 años
contra el extremismo
bienvenidos a un informativo nuevo de
france 24 soy rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos esta
emisión en brasil en donde las
inundaciones y deslizamientos han dejado
al menos 66 muertos y decenas de casas
destruidas en la ciudad de petrópolis
tras las lluvias extremas del martes
mientras continúa la búsqueda conjunta
entre civiles servicios de emergencia y
ejército de sobrevivientes hasta el
momento 21 personas fueron rescatadas
vivas bajo los escombros nuestra
corresponsal en río de janeiro valeria
saccone no se ampliaba más temprano esta
información los bomberos siguen
trabajando contrarreloj en petrópolis
para encontrar a supervivientes tras las
fuertes lluvias de ayer que causaron al
menos
189 deslizamientos 21 personas han sido
rescatadas con vida pero hay muchas
denuncias de desaparecidos el centro de
petrópolis parece un escenario de guerra
hay mucha destrucción cabe explicar que
es una localidad turística en la que
muchos cariocas pasan el verano porque
huyen del calor es una región serrana
rodeada de montañas y este es
precisamente el problema con las lluvias
hay deslizamientos todos los años solo
que la lluvia de ayer ha sido
especialmente fuerte en dos horas
cayeron 260 milímetros de agua y peor la
previsión de hoy de más lluvias aunque
moderadas por eso los equipos de
protección civil están en alerta cabe
destacar para terminar que no es la
primera vez que en esta región se
registra una tragedia medioambiental en
2011 hubo fuerte deslizamientos de
tierra en teresópolis en aquella ocasión
murieron más de 900 personas un
terremoto de magnitud 6 con 2 en la
escala richter sacudió guatemala y deja
ya al menos 2 muertos según las
autoridades ambas víctimas habrían
fallecido por ataques cardiacos como
consecuencia del temblor
las autoridades cuantifican también
deslaves en carreteras daños en casas y
cortes de luz en varios puntos del país
el epicentro del sismo tuvo lugar a 16
kilómetros de tiquisate en la costa
pacífica del país a una profundidad de
96 kilómetros y fue seguido de otras
tres réplicas de menor magnitud
decenas de periodistas mexicanos
salieron a las calles del país para
protestar por el asesinato de cinco
reporteros en menos de dos meses una
escalada de la violencia contra los
informantes que no cesa las
organizaciones periodísticas denuncian
que más del 90% de estas muertes siguen
sin resolverse y exigen al gobierno
mexicano garantías y protección para
ejercer el periodismo en el que es según
reporteros sin fronteras el país más
letal para la prensa marina sardenya con
los detalles
con el lema matando periodistas no se
mata la verdad decenas de personas se
manifestaron frente a las instituciones
en varias ciudades mexicanas ante la
oleada de asesinatos de reporteros 5 en
lo que va de año el más reciente ever
lópez quien fue baleado en su oficina en
la ciudad de oaxaca en el suroeste del
país
y exigimos garantías para exterior
también exigimos que los asesinatos de
nuestros y nuestras
no queden impunes y que su labor
considerada las líneas de investigación
justicia real
de simulación en la investigación que
supuestamente
autoridades denunciar crímenes informar
sobre corrupción o narcotráfico puede
costarle la vida a los periodistas
locales mexicanos son reporteros sin
fronteras méxico es el país más letal
para ejercer el oficio periodístico
similar a reportar desde una zona de
guerra las organizaciones como artículo
19 que documentan estas matanzas
denuncian que el 40 por ciento de estas
muertes recae en funcionarios públicos y
piden protección y el esclarecimiento de
estos casos un pedido al que se unió la
unión europea a través de un comunicado
ante el alarmante número de agresiones
contra periodistas en el país urgimos a
todas las autoridades competentes a
hacer uso de todos los medios a su
alcance para generar entornos favorables
para que las personas periodistas de
méxico puedan ejercer su profesión
libremente y sin amenazas el gobierno de
lópez obrador está siendo criticado
desde las organizaciones que denuncian
que el mandatario no ha cumplido sus
promesas de reducir la violencia y la
impunidad en el país te apoyen en canadá
a la policía de ottawa advirtió a los
manifestantes anti vacunas de la capital
que habrá detenciones si no levantan sus
protestas
2 en la ley de emergencias activada el
lunes por el primer ministro ya string
crudo la policía declaró ilegal el
bloqueo del centro de la ciudad con
camiones y exigió que se levanten de
inmediato las protestas el 80% de los
canadienses están completamente
vacunados
no tengo miedo de ser arrestado si eso
es lo que sus capitanes y el jefe de la
policía quieren aportar a esta protesta
pacífica es violencia entonces eso es
cosa suya estamos aquí pacíficamente y
seguiremos así incluso se intentan
detener nos nos detendrán pacíficamente
los gastos we would be our
los aliados occidentales exigen a rusia
pruebas concretas de la desescalada
refutando las afirmaciones de moscú de
que ha empezado a retirar las tropas de
su frontera con ucrania la otan cuyos
ministros de defensa se reúnen este
miércoles y jueves en bruselas afirma
que rusia continúa con su despliegue
militar esto se produce cuando el
ministerio de defensa ruso ha publicado
imágenes de vehículos blindados
alejándose de crimea
en estas imágenes publicadas por el
ministerio de defensa ruso se muestran
camiones militares cruzando el puente de
crimea aparentemente abandonando la
península del mar negro moscú dice que
es parte del retorno de las fuerzas a
sus bases permanentes pero no es
suficiente para convencer a los aliados
occidentales
hemos escuchado las señales de moscú
sobre la voluntad de continuar los
esfuerzos diplomáticos pero hasta ahora
no hemos visto ninguna desescalada sobre
el terreno por el contrario parece que
rusia continúa con la concentración
militar
contingente militar y boudou a pesar de
que rusia ha anunciado la retirada de
sus tropas de la frontera ucraniana la
otan dijo que sería preparada para lo
peor
el presidente ruso vladimir putin señaló
que quería una vía diplomática para
salir de la crisis diciendo que moscú no
quiere una guerra con europa la unión
europea sin embargo se ha hecho eco de
los llamamientos a una desescalada
concreta y estrecha ayer rusia envió
ciertamente señales contradictorias por
un lado las autoridades anunciaron la
retirada de las tropas rusas
la tumba bota el reconocimiento formal
de dones y lugar como repúblicas
independientes sweet flex el martes la
duma la cámara baja del parlamento ruso
y esto a putin a reconocer la
independencia de dos regiones
separatistas respaldadas por rusia en el
este de ucrania
la medida anularían gran medida los
protocolos de minsk firmados por moscú y
kiev en 2014 y 2015 aunque los acuerdos
nunca se aplicaron en su totalidad
garantizaban que las regiones seguirían
formando parte de ucrania el canciller
alemán olaf scholz dijo que sería un
desastre político si el kremlin firmará
el reconocimiento
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
recibe a líderes africanos para discutir
cómo combatir a los extremistas en la
región del sahel se espera que francia
anuncie la retirada de tropas en mali en
un momento en que los lazos entre
francia y su antigua colonia son cada
vez más hostiles luego de que bamako
expulsar al embajador francés el mes
pasado
en su lucha contra el terrorismo en el
sahel en enero de 2013 el entonces
presidente de francia françois hollande
lanzó una operación cuyo único objetivo
era detener el terrorismo en la región
en ese momento la operación el serbal
desplegó las tropas francesas para
impedir que los extremistas islamistas
se apoderaran del norte de mali en pocos
meses las tropas fundamentalistas habían
sido derrotadas la operación serbal
evolucionó entonces hacia la operación
var hand y en 2014 se formó el g5 sahel
reagrupando a los cinco principales
actores de la región mauritania mali y
burkina faso níger y chad pero con menos
fuerzas francesas sobre el terreno y
enfrentándose a una gran resistencia el
g-5 tuvo problemas en noviembre de 2015
al qaeda del magreb islámico' atacó el
hotel radisson blu de bamako tomando 100
rehenes y matando a 20 personas antes de
que las fuerzas especiales malienses
pusieran fin al asedio unos meses más
tarde en enero de 2016 hombres armados
asaltaron un restaurante y el hotel
splendid en uagadugú en respuesta a la
creciente inestabilidad en la región el
presidente manuel mccone y los miembros
del g5 lanzaron el fcg 5s una fuerza
fronteriza conjunta para atacar a los
terroristas en cualquier país del sahel
pero los ataques continuaron y la
estabilidad ha sido difícil de mantener
en 2020 y 2021 malí se vio sacudida por
dos golpes militares
las protestas que acusan al ejército
francés de atacar a civiles en
bombardeos aéreos han deteriorado mucho
la situación en los últimos meses
tensiones que culminaron con la
expulsión del embajador francés en enero
bamako también ordenó la retirada de las
fuerzas especiales danesas del país
noruega es el último socio europeo que
ha abandonado sus planes de enviar
tropas a mali atribuyendo la decisión a
la falta de garantías para la seguridad
de sus soldados
en mogadiscio la capital de somalia dos
ataques perpetrados por el grupo
yihadista al shabab dejaron al menos
ocho fallecidos y 16 heridos el primer
ataque del grupo yihadista vinculado a
al-qaeda tuvo lugar en una comisaría de
policía en el distrito de cada según las
autoridades dos de las víctimas mortales
serían niños
amnistía internacional denunció en un
nuevo reporte el reporte las atrocidades
cometidas en la región del tigre en
etiopía en medio de los enfrentamientos
entre las fuerzas de seguridad y los
rebeldes que buscan el control de la
zona la organización responsabilizó a
las fuerzas de seguridad de amará por
una oleada de detenciones masivas
homicidios y expulsiones forzadas de
personas de la etnia en el territorio de
tigre occidental que intentaban escapar
de la violencia
la nueva embestida de abusos de las
fuerzas de amhara contra los civiles que
quedan en varias localidades del oeste
de tigre deberían hacer sonar las
alarmas sin una acción internacional
urgente para evitar más atrocidades los
tigray anos en particular los detenidos
corren un grave riesgo
hong kong que había logrado contener el
cob y 19 durante casi dos años registra
un pico de contagios que tiene
desbordados los hospitales que han
llegado al cien por ciento de su
capacidad este miércoles las autoridades
hongkonesas confirmaron un récord de
cuatro mil 285 nuevas infecciones una
cifra más de 40 veces superior a las
registradas a inicios de febrero
la polución es más mortal que el cobre
19 eso resume un informe publicado por
la onu en el que alerta sobre los
problemas en la salud que causan
productos químicos como insecticidas
plásticos y residuos electrónicos el
problema de la contaminación también
puede afectar al aumento de gases de
efecto invernadero
una acción inmediata y ambiciosa para
prohibir productos químicos tóxicos
esto pidiera uno en un informe
medioambiental donde advierte que las
muertes por la polución son mayores a
las producidas por la pandemia la
contaminación está matando a más
personas cada año que las que la
pandemia de kobe 19 ha matado en el
transcurso de los últimos dos años y sin
embargo no recibe ni de lejos la
atención del público o de los
responsables políticos la contaminación
por plaguicidas plásticos y residuos
electrónicos causa más de 9 millones de
muertes al año el documento insta a que
se limpien los lugares contaminados y
sean reubicadas en casos extremos las
comunidades afectadas pobres indígenas o
marginadas que viven en las llamadas
zonas de sacrificio este término
utilizado originalmente para describir
las zonas de pruebas nucleares se amplió
en el informe para incluir cualquier
sitio muy contaminado o inhabitable por
el cambio climático lista estas zonas de
sacrificios se encuentran no sólo en los
países pobres sino que se encuentran en
los países ricos
mientras la administración nacional
oceánica y atmosférica de eeuu noaa
lanza otra advertencia el nivel del mar
podría subir en este país de 25 a 30
centímetros en promedio para 2050
una de las afirmaciones más profundas de
este informe es que se espera que eeuu
experimente en 30 años un aumento del
nivel del mar tan grande como el que
vimos durante todo el siglo pasado
el aumento de los niveles de los océanos
producidos en gran medida por el
derretimiento de los polos a causa del
cambio climático podría empeorar si no
se reducen los gases efecto invernadero
y hasta aquí este nuevo repaso de la
actividad internacional les invitamos a
seguir conectados en france24 y ampliar
toda la información en france 24 punto
com
[Música]